were often told in physics that the
presence of massive bodies warps the
fabric of space and time
but what does such a statement actually
mean
most visuals are heuristic tools that
don't offer clear understanding
leaving one to wonder is it possible to
actually visualize space-time curvature
especially near an object so massive we
can cross a limit of no return
this is dialect with
the geometry of a black hole
what does the curvature of space and
time around a massive body actually look
like
to answer this question we need to turn
to a mathematical object called the
Schwartz Shield metric
presented in tensor form this metric is
a matrix with four Expressions along its
diagonal components
now in our prior videos we demonstrated
how the components of a metric tensor
can be interpreted as instructions for
resizing infinitesimal pieces of a map
in order to fit those pieces to a curved
surface
and indeed this is the case whether your
map is one of a physical surface like
that of the Earth
or whether it's a map of a more abstract
surface like that of the space-time
manifold
we can thus use the Schwartz Shield
metric to construct for ourselves a
model of curved space-time
but first we must get our hands on the
map which the metric belongs to
here we turn to what's formerly known as
the spark Shield coordinate chart
this map depicts space-time in the
vicinity of a single centrally located
non-rotating uncharged spherical Mass
now just as there's no one right way to
map out the curved surface of the Earth
onto a two-dimensional Cartesian grid
there's no one right way to map out the
curved surface of space-time onto a
four-dimensional Cartesian grid
consequently we have a choice in how to
make such a projection
motivated by the spherical symmetry of
the region the Schwartz Shield approach
is to assign to every world event that
occurs
a set of more or less spherical like
coordinates
t r Theta and Phi
the first coordinate T is intended to be
analogous to a traditional time
coordinate
as there is no Global time in this
region and clocks everywhere tick at
different rates
the simplest solution for describing
time here is simply to choose a Master
Clock meaning a clock against which all
others can be compared
the Natural Choice will be that of a
clock belonging to a distant Observer
since far out from the Central Mass
space-time curvature will be negligible
all events which transpire across this
space-time region
are thus assigned a Time coordinate
based on whenever this distant Observer
perceives them to occur
foreign
the second coordinate R is analogous to
a radial coordinate
it is produced by placing observers in
concentric Rings about the mass
then having those observers measure the
circumferences of the Rings
in order to deduce
via dividing by 2 pi
what the respective radii of the Rings
would be were the overall geometry of
the space-time region there flat
this is like making a bird's eye map of
a circularly symmetric Hill
the radial distance between any point
and the top of the hill obviously
depends on the Hill's curvature and
grade
but once projected onto a flat surface
this distance instead becomes the
circumference of the Contour which the
point occupies divided by 2 pi
meanwhile the third and fourth
coordinates Theta and Phi retain their
ordinary meaning from spherical
coordinates as the polar and azimuthal
angles about the Central Mass
together these four coordinates once
assigned to every event map out with
time and space would look like in this
region if space-time were flat
but of course space-time isn't flat here
it's curved
which is why once we feed our map into
Einstein's equations
out pops the schwarzchil metric telling
us how our artificially constructed
coordinates relate to the true
space-time geometry
now since the last two components of
this metric are the same as they would
be in flat space time
for the time being it'll be simpler to
drop them from the picture and only
consider a two-dimensional space-time
manifold
don't worry though we'll add those
Dimensions back in later
we are now ready to transform our map
I.E the smart Shield coordinate chart
into an actual space-time surface
the procedure is simple
to start we cut the map into many tiny
Square pieces
Dr by DT
then we simply follow the instructions
from the metric tensor
now the first instruction tells us by
how much we need to stretch or Shrink
the coordinative DT length of each map
piece in order to match it to its true
surface length I.E that length of proper
time an observer located there would
experience
here that value corresponds to the
square root of 1 minus 2gm divided by c
squared times the r coordinate of that
piece
foreign
we can see that for very large R
coordinates this expression takes on a
value of nearly one
meaning that the temporal lengths of
pieces far from the Central Mass will
remain essentially unchanged
for smaller R coordinates however this
expression takes on values increasingly
less and less than one
meaning that the temporal lengths of
pieces closer and closer to the Central
Mass will be more and more shrunk
physically this means that from the
perspective of the distant Observer
clocks closer to the Central Mass will
appear to run more slowly than clocks
farther away
next the second instruction from the
metric tensor tells us by how much we
need to stretch or Shrink the Dr length
of our piece in order to match it to its
true surface length I.E the length of
proper distance an observer located
there would measure
here that value is just the reciprocal
of the former expression
meaning anywhere we saw temporal lengths
decrease
spatial lengths will increase by the
same factor
pieces far from the Central Mass then
will just as with the temporal case see
their spatial lengths remain relatively
unchanged while closer to the mass
pieces will see their spatial lengths
increasingly stretched
foreign
physically this means that from the
perspective of a distant Observer rulers
closer to the Central Mass will appear
more and more contracted
we now have all the correctly resized
pieces of our space-time map
meaning we are looking at our
spatio-temporal reality in its true
proportions
at this point let's draw in proper space
and time grids on each piece
this will help us understand how the
flow of time and space will look across
different points of the manifold
now although we lack a meaningful higher
dimensional coordinate transformation
with which to appropriately reassemble
these pieces thanks to the fact that we
have suppressed the other two dimensions
of space we still have a third dimension
left over to play with
although we can't interpret this extra
Dimension as anything real
there's no reason we can't use it to Aid
in our visualization either
so let's put the puzzle together
the trick here is to First roll the
entire surface up in a cylindrical
fashion
and then to bend the tapered edges in
towards one another until adjacent
pieces are all touching
and voila there we have it what the
curvature of space-time in the vicinity
of a massive object actually looks like
now note here that where the surface
curves around it doesn't actually rejoin
itself
rather as we move along the temporal
direction we can imagine the surface
getting continually rolled up like a
large sheet of paper
also note that the boundary of the
manifold lies at the edge of the Central
Mass as the schwarzshield solution can't
be extended to the masses interior
lastly to make this picture more
accurate we can repeat this process with
smaller and smaller pieces until we
essentially have approximated a smooth
manifold
next let us consider the motion of two
distinct observers sitting together out
at some coordinate radius r on this
manifold
one Observer is inertial or Free Falling
and the other is accelerating in order
to maintain constant radial distance
from the mass
over a very short period of time they
follow the same world line together on
the manifold
but in the next instant the velocity of
the accelerated Observer increases with
respect to the inertial Observer and
their world lines diverge
now the proper grid on this next
manifold piece depicts space and time as
measured at a constant radial distance
meaning it belongs to the accelerated
Observer not the inertial Observer
thus we must transform into the frame of
the accelerated Observer
which results in The inertial Observers
World line being deflected inwards
towards the Central Mass
high up along the manifold where the
curvature is weak the amount of this
deflection will be very slight but
further down it becomes more and more
substantial
foreign
inertial or free-falling object starts
out moving purely in the temporal
Direction
the curvature of the manifold soon helps
redirect it down towards the Central
Mass
to see this better we can keep the
object on a constant radial line
and depict the progression of time as a
rolling of the manifold
as though it were being rotated about an
axis running through its Center
from this perspective as the manifold
rolls forwards in time the object begins
to fall faster and faster down towards
the Central Mass
next we can add our missing spatial
Dimensions back into the picture
to do this we first draw radial lines
outwards from the mass then we attach a
rolling manifold to each line
the visualization gets a bit awkward
here as we are superimposing multiple
manifolds atop one another
but next we can sort of squash out the
temporal rolling leaving only a visual
of the radial motions
now we see that we have a
three-dimensional space where all
objects fall steadily inwards towards
the Central Mass as time progresses
I.E we have reproduced a classical
gravitational field
so we can see how the geometry of
space-time helps create the illusion of
gravity
but what happens if the curvature of our
manifold becomes so great that there
exists a limit of no return
well returning to our Schwartz Shield
metric we see that for a certain value
of the r coordinate R equals 2gm over c
squared
the temporal component of the metric
goes to zero
while the spatial one blows up to
Infinity
in terms of resizing our map
this means that pieces near this R
coordinate value
will become extremely thin and long
when constructing the surface then these
pieces will ultimately converge at a
single point
sealing off the space-time manifold
there
this point is quite literally the point
of no return
the object's Event Horizon
if this object is heavy and dense enough
The Event Horizon will lie exterior to
its mass and it will be dubbed a black
hole
let's again look at the motion of two
observers but now near this manifold's
event horizon
as they cross from one instant to the
next the world line of the free-falling
Observer will be deflected by an amount
almost equal to the world line of light
foreign
s The Accelerated observer's velocity
has to increase by nearly the speed of
light in order for them to remain at a
stationary radial distance
once the inertial Observer Falls past
the Event Horizon
their speed is essentially now faster
than the speed of light at least
relative to The Observers outside the
Event Horizon
meaning they are causally cut off from
the rest of the universe
so there we have it the geometry of a
black hole guess it turns out our higher
dimensional reality rather looks
something like a bullet
a joke from God perhaps
well at the end of the day this is still
only a visualization and consequently
there are a few things that do need to
be qualified about it as well as a few
things that are incomplete about it
but those matters require a deeper dive
into both relativity and topology
so stay tuned as we'll continue
exploring the meaning of space-time
curvature in future videos
this has been dialect thanks for
watching